globalizzazione rivoluzione digitale
hanno modificato il nostro essere
cittadini all'interno del mercato 5.0 in
realtà che i nostri padri fosse più
visionare immaginavano creavano nella
loro mente ma che oggi nel corso degli
ultimi 20 anni è diventato realtà una
realtà complessa una realtà complessa da
gestire
in realtà caratterizzata da miriade di
variabili che ogni giorno modificano il
nostro vivere quotidiano
sembra inutile e forse banale città e
tutto ciò che si sta modificando
parliamo dei baricentri economici
parliamo della geopolitica parliamo nel
nostro essere cittadini in termini di
servizi di richieste di servizi ma è
ancora più intrinseco forse ancora più
profondo il nostro essere in armonia con
gli altri nostro benessere
ebbene riconosciamo quindi la necessità
di costruire una cultura una cultura che
possa mettere il suo stesso piano
identità e territorio da un lato e
digitale progresso futuro dall'altro in
un'equa distribuzione con la sinergia
con solidarietà e di inclusività è bene
parliamo qui di cultura e inclusività
digitale parliamo di benessere
ecosostenibile parliamo di transizione
energetica parliamo di economia
circolare
parliamo di mobilità e coesione
territoriale di tematiche che il nostro
futuro e il nostro essere cittadini e
deve affrontare ma in primis e lo deve
affrontare la nostra azione come
generazione lavorativa come generazione
politica come generazione istituzionale
ebbene affrontando queste tematiche si
si si percepisce come un'analisi molto
più contestualizzata un'analisi molto
più ampia ci fa capire ci fa comprendere
come esiste una fortissima di scherzi a
sociale tra ciò che produciamo e ciò che
abbiamo tra ciò che vogliamo e ciò è ciò
che vogliamo essere e ancora una
discrasia economica ciò che noi
produciamo e ciò che in realtà noi
consumiamo e ancora una discrasia
politica istituzionale
ciò che noi vorremmo che venisse
rappresentata e ciò che invece è
rappresentato tutte grandi crisi che
oggi necessita però di una sintesi e
trovare una nuova armonia basata sulla
fune una flessibilità mentale una
cultura che possa andare oltre questo
tipo di ostacolo
ebbene da dove partiamo partiamo da
quella distruzione creativa del mondo
del lavoro in cui la nostra generazione
parlo in particolare della mia e si è
trovata protagonista in questo tipo di
in questo tipo di rivoluzione punto
fondamentale la formazione e
l'informazione ossia quella capacità di
essere a stesso tempo aggregatore di
informazione ma si possa per insegnare
saper mettere in connessione mentre in
condivisione ciò che noi sappiamo senza
trovare barriere intergenerazionali
e ancora l'importanza di avere una
cultura digitale non semplicemente della
strumentazione digitale porre una forma
mentis che metta a sistema ciò che
sappiamo è ciò che vorremmo sapere in
un'ottica di sinergia in un'ottica di
visione in un'ottica di sistema è
proprio su questo punto in cui noi
vogliamo essere qualcuno e quindi
un'identità forte e quindi tra forte
culturale a suo tempo digitale c'è
necessità di tecnologie che possono dare
questa sicurezza che possono dare questo
tipo di visione in primis la brook c'è
intesa proprio come quella tecnologia
che può dare sicurezza garanzie
immutabilità del dato possa dare
risparmio è ancora più specificatamente
trinci ossia quella con capacità di
essere una tecnologia open source sara
prati di tutti proprio perché il
concetto di distribuzione il concetto di
liberalizzazione del pensiero è il suo
tempo però di garanzia di ciò che
facciamo è corretto di ciò che facciamo
è sicuro e simbolo di simbolo non
soltanto di sicurezza ma è il simbolo di
validità e ancora parliamo da un
concetto ancora più semplice la nostra
identità intesa come territorio intesa
come comune quel tipo di indennità ha
bisogno assolutamente di essere
preservata oggi più che mai esiste una
desertificazione delle città esiste la
necessità sempre di più di essere
apportate in connessione col mondo e
tante volte luoghi magnifici luoghi
incantati rischio di essere spazzati via
e cancellati da un punto di vista
identitario e democratico
oggi più che mai la tecnologia ci deve
essere ci deve servire perché questi
posti questi luoghi possano coniugare
quello che nel medioevo quello che
rinascimento è riusciti a fare ossia
tecnologia
e quindi ingegno da un lato e identità
dall'altro le eccellenze non possono
spostarsi le eccellenze non possono
trovarsi in un unico punto licenze
devono essere distribuiti in maniera
equa in una maniera sostenibile anche da
un punto di vista economico
e ancora partiamo dalla qualità della
vita oggi più che mai si sente la forte
presenza di una crisi climatica che a
posto e non si possono essere in
disequilibrio con l'ambiente in cui noi
viviamo oggi ce ne cita quindi un
investimento nelle nuove tecnologie
proprio per preservare il nostro habitat
per preservare la nostra salute
in primis c'e necessita quindi di
comprendere e approfondire le più
moderne tecnologie per quanto riguarda
il tema della telemedicina fondamentale
soprattutto in un'epoca come questa dove
esiste e si percepisce non solo una
crisi sanitaria ma possibili crisi
sanitarie
oggi come nel futuro e ancora
immaginiamo un modello economico come
quello dell'economia circolare come
qualcosa di assodato come qualcosa che
non può essere messo in discussione
l'importanza dell'impatto sociale il
benessere delle aziende di passa anche
per benessere della collettività se
starò bene aziende poi può star bene
anche la collettività e viceversa creare
quell humus culturale in cui quindi
azienda in cui cittadini in cui
istituzione in cui ognuno di noi
qualunque tipo di realtà possa essere in
armonia possa trovare quella giusta
distribuzione di servizi ricchezza
metodo linguaggio comune e ancora c'è
necessità di una visione che possa
andare oltre ancora questo questi questi
paradigmi una visione che ponga l'uomo
al centro del nostro del nostro essere
come se fosse una società partecipata
deve ritornare al centro con un suo 51
per cento riprendersi in mano ciò che
ciò che tante volte con uno spaesamento
machiavellico ha più volte ha più volte
evidenziato a più volte così
riconosciuto non per una mancanza di di
polis non per una mancanza di divisa ma
semplicemente perché i fatti in realtà
si sono moltiplicate perché le variabili
ci sono
duplicate perché il nostro essere essere
vivente non essere quotidiano e una
gestione continua di complessità e di
valore che tante volte è difficile da
canalizzare promuovere e soprattutto da
riconosce all'interno di una città che
giorno dopo giorno distrugge ma
distrugge in maniera creativa e
riformula in una maniera diversificata
proprio su questo punto la necessità di
tutti noi oggi è quello di trovare
sintesi sintesi di mercato sintesi
culturale sintesi politica non perché
dobbiamo ridurre o dobbiamo essere
superficiale ma perché dobbiamo trovare
connettività
dobbiamo trovare condivisione dobbiamo
trovare quella quella chiave di volta
che per tutti noi rappresenta la chiave
del dell'armonia tra noi esseri umani e
tra il sistema in cui noi viviamo questa
chiave di volta può essere variabile non
esiste una soluzione unica perché per
trovare la la retta via
quello che vi permette di dire quello
che posso diciamo testimoniare che
esiste una generazione pronta ad
accettare questa sfida pronta accettare
questo tipo di coinvolgimento in tutti i
suoi settori e in tutte le sue forme
un investimento nelle nuove generazioni
investimento nell'innovazione e nella
formazione di nuove generazioni porta
con sé la responsabilità e la coscienza
nazionale di investire in qualcosa che è
oggi cresce domani può corre ma
soprattutto vuole e testimonia la
volontà di voler vivere in questo
sistema e non semplicemente sopravvivere
questa è la forza d'animo che testimonia
la volontà di non vedere crisi di non
vedere limitazioni di non vedere
problemi ma quello di trovare soluzioni
le soluzioni che però hanno bisogno di
quella cultura di quella cultura di
quella formazione che oggi in italia
oggi nel mondo oggi grazie anche a ted
possiamo testimoniare e possiamo mettere
a fattore comune
io insieme a voi voi insieme a me
noi tutti in un'ottica di un grande io
che si mente a testimonianza di ognuno
di noi